today i'm going to be speaking with
alexandra hudson who's an award-winning
journalist author and speaker as well as
the founder of civic renaissance her new
book is against politeness why
politeness failed america and how
civility can save it it's so great
having you on i really appreciate it
thanks david for having me
so i mean i think to start with we
should talk about the difference between
politeness and civility there's so much
discussion particularly in modern
politics about
many people aren't civil or can we
continue to be civil
versus politeness which is really
something different so maybe let's start
there like what are these two different
concepts
it's a it's a good question that's
that's the core thesis of of my
forthcoming book that there is this
difference but i think a lot of people
today fail to recognize there's a
difference we use these two terms
civility and politeness interchangeably
and that makes it difficult to think
okay what do we want less of in society
and what do we want more of
because people today they either long
for more civility more politeness they
long for these days of gentility and
chivalry
and think society's going to hell in a
hand basket or they want less of
plainness they think that it's uh they
want they think it's civility is a tool
of of white supremacy a tool of social
oppression
a tool of social injustice so i argue
that by making this distinction we can
again have more clarity about what we're
talking about we want what we want so i
argue that uh politeness is a technique
it's manners it's the superficial
expression of you know social norms and
etiquette
um civility by contrast is a disposition
it's a way of looking at others and the
world and seeing other people as human
beings just like us with equal moral
worth and with beings with dignity and
worth and worthy of respect and the
etymology of these two terms supports
that distinction the the root word uh
politeness is the latin word poliair
which means to smooth or polish and
that's what politeness does again it
focuses on the external um
whereas civility that the latin root is
kivitos or kevis which is city or
citizen and and civility connotes the
the conduct befitting a member of the
city or a citizen of the duties of
citizenship so i think it's important to
make these this distinction to know you
know what do we want more of and what do
we want less of in society for many
people they might be thinking about
these concepts in the context of
conversations they have with you know
their uncle at thanksgiving or whatever
the case may be can you kind of apply
this
to
such interpersonal conversations and
give us examples of of how civility and
politeness
can overlap but also one can exist
absent the other and kind of what that
would look like in human interaction
absolutely
i'm of the mind that
civility is actually
the truly respectful way of engaging
with others because seeing people as
human beings first with equal moral
worth so whereas politeness would want
to smooth over differences um civility
says i respect you enough david to tell
you when i think you're terribly wrong
on a subject i'm not going to patronize
you and just smile when i think that
you're incorrect i'm going to tell you
what i think that's that truly
respectful thing to do however and again
that's what a democracy requires it
requires having being able to have
robust honest discourse and not just um
you know suppressing discussion or
papering over important differences
however i will note that not all
contexts in life are the same you know
having a debate in a college classroom
or on the floors of of congress is
different than having a dinner with your
family member and i'm a firm believer
that
politics has taken too much of our
consciousness and our psychiatrist is
too much a part of our lives and there
are way more important things in
politics such as relationships with
family members and i i don't think that
you have to fight to death on every
single political issue it's it's too
easy to let political issues come
between relationships and family family
family relationships these days and so i
think it's perfectly fine to say you
know what we're not going to talk about
xyz issue we're not going to talk about
politics at all because because we're
going to talk about other things you
know our kids or you know our lives
because this relationship matters more
than focusing on you know the sore spots
the areas of disagreement that may not
be um reconcilable right now yeah
sometimes viewers will call me and
they'll say hey you know like for
example a left-wing viewer will call and
say
uh when i go back to
wherever during college break you know
my parents have turned into the opposite
of what i am they watch fox news all day
and they think joe biden lost and they
think the vaccines turn you into a
turtle and you know all these different
things um how can i
change their mind
and
and my answer always is well what what
are you willing to allow to happen to
your relationship with them because i
can i could answer in terms of how minds
are sometimes changed but part of it is
are you willing to not have a
relationship with them anymore or you
need to figure that out first so to
speak and it seems that that
is missing sometimes from just figuring
out how can i have my ideas win over
someone someone else's
and i think that's reflective of this
mentality in our political discourse
today where it's all zero sum it's like
i have to win and it's and i'm gonna win
at all costs it's like you know scorched
earth policy and you can't take that
logic and apply it to our relationships
and our family and our family context um
hey i don't think that's the right thing
to do and and b uh that's not the right
thing to do generally you can't have a
democracy with that sort of skirt
scorched earth zero sum uh mindset
that's part of my part the conclusion of
my book argues that again we have we
suffer from a crisis of misplaced
meaning in our society today where these
traditional touchstones family civil
society church these are all kind of on
the rescindent and in recent years and
and politics has become the place where
we derive our meaning from which is why
which is why every political issue it
like cuts us to our core someone
disagrees with us it's like we're being
personally assaulted and we go into
fight-or-flight mode as opposed to if we
have these other
derived our meaning from other places we
could have kind of the equanimity of
spirit to be able to have these
difficult conversations but we we've
allowed politics to matter too much to
us which is why it's difficult to have
these conversations well before we move
on to the more like governmental level
application of this to keep it at the
personal a little bit there are no doubt
people who will hear this conversation
and they'll say well you know guys
alexander david uh uh there are
circumstances where it's not that i'm
looking for a fight but
i cannot be civil nor polite uh with
people who for example if i were gay and
i know that there i'm around people
whether it's parents or co-workers or
whatever who quite literally believe
that i'm going to hell i'm an evil
person or whatever something so
fundamental to what i am and who i am
it's not that i'm trying to make
political disagreements the forefront
but
i can't be civil with someone who sees
me in that way it's very easy to say
let's not make it all about politics we
don't have but when it's something so
core to who i am
i can't be civil i can't be polite it's
not possible
there's validity to that as well isn't
there
of course and i absolutely empathize
with that position i would however point
uh people of that mindset to a really
powerful example of someone who lives
out uh lives out uh decency with people
that that that he disagrees with to say
the least that the jazz
uh uh musician daryl davis if you
haven't heard of him so he's been on the
show yeah awesome yeah exactly his his
story is incredible where he he he makes
um you know makes it his personal
mission in life to win over white
supremacists who literally think he's a
sub-human and he does it through
conversation and kindness and
relationship um no one's ever been
persuaded to change their mind about
anything by being insulted and like hit
over the head with with rationality and
arguments and he really embodies the
ethos of saying you know i'm going to
see the personhood past the bigotry um
and i'm going to try and reach that and
and focus on what we have in common and
he's changed a lot of hearts and minds
that way that's a really powerful
example for each of us
yeah what he does is is really
incredible um when it comes to national
and world level politics are there some
examples of of when politeness led to
bad outcomes or results that we could
talk through
well politeness across history has been
this tool of division it's been it's
been a way of signifying the in-group
and the out-group both country both
within between countries and within a
given uh society it's been a way for uh
people to feel superior to others um uh
in ancient greece for example um they
anyone who didn't speak greek and have
the manners of of greek people were
we're called barbarians that's where we
get our word uh barbarian from it's when
someone it means someone who basically
doesn't speak greek and and for the
greeks they didn't leave it as okay they
just speak a different language and they
have different manners than us
for them they said okay they're
different from us therefore they're
morally inferior and they're less like
they're lesser than us and that logic
that kind of thinking is not unique to
the ancient greeks we see that all
across culture all across history um and
even through to today in the american
gildan age for example the fabulous new
hbo show called the gilded age that i'm
loving right now every monday night and
that's a great example of of how manners
and and social norms and politeness was
weaponized to keep the the nouveau reach
the parva news the rockefellers and the
carnegie's they were the new vogrish
they're the names that we remember now
but they were the out group they were
the ones that uh the old money and
society wanted to keep out and so emily
emily vanderbilt's you know big um tome
and on etiquette and emily post as well
those are all etiquette books on you
know handbooks for how to be a social
elite that actually um the middle class
and immigrants who came to america
started reading and saying oh my gosh
this is what it means to be an american
and they kind of it helped them
assimilate it was kind of a shorthand
for how to how to do this thing called
life together so what originally started
as this project of exclusion ended up
being a way to invite and welcome the
newcomer into society yeah that's
interesting i've heard from people who
grew did not grow up necessarily with
parents that were able to inform them of
of a lot of kind of social norms and
etiquette stuff talk about i got into
college and then the job fairs and and
they realized at a certain point when
they would get to either these group
interviews or different things it wasn't
that they were
less able or knowledgeable when it came
to the subject matter but they realized
they didn't know all the social norms
even when things things as simple as
when everybody sits at a table to a meal
and there's sort of like a pecking order
in terms of like were the people doing
the hiring were the people they and they
knew they were at a disadvantage
specifically for those reasons
absolutely i think too often we assume
we know someone's character you know
their their inner state by the the
shorthand by manners whether they know
which fork to use and again this is how
the norms of politeness have been
weaponized across human history and part
of my argument with my for my book is is
we need to
focus less on those the trimmings you
know focus less on the etiquette more on
the timeless principles of civility that
have served us well in this project of
human community across time and place i
argue that you know civility is not a
new problem it's not an america problem
it's not a now problem it is a human
problem which is why every single
society without fail across history has
had etiquette books that's a whole gene
and they've had social norms that help
us do this thing called life together
it's hard society and civilization is
fragile and it takes work and if we're
not all doing this together not we're
not all part of this you know thing
called society together um it's gonna
fall apart and we we we've seen like we
we have um we're watching you know
civilization fall apart in the ukraine
right now we like war war is is very
much a part of um of our world today and
uh we can't take that for granted we
have to remember the role that we each
have in supporting this this thing
called a free society this thing called
a democracy and this thing called human
community hey when it comes to someone
like donald trump you know the the
making fun of a disabled reporter and
the thing rosie o'donnell i don't
remember as a dog or as fat or whatever
you know all the coarse language and all
that stuff
did did trump change expectations of
politeness or civility in politics
i think that's an interesting question
there is no doubt that
he he did coarsen our public discourse
in a lot of ways
but his his
two things i think his um the crassness
of his language the candor i think a lot
of people saw that as truth-telling that
was the you know people saw that as okay
he's being honest and civil people are
sick of the politeness the veneer the
the political correctness people are
sick of being suppressed and and you
know the language policing that was
going on he cut through the hypocrisy of
all that and i think that appealed to a
lot of people which is um kind of why i
make the argument that we need to care
less about the form care less about the
the politeness and more about civility
the honest truth telling that we need
for democracy so i think he tapped into
a really important insight that people
have been sensing and intuiting for a
really long time but secondly it is
really important that to realize that
donald trump did not create our civility
problem again this is not a new problem
not an america problem this is a human
problem it's been a challenge to human
community so i i argue in my book that
as human beings we are profoundly social
we thrive we become fully human in
community but we're also profoundly
selfish and self-interested we aim to
meet our needs uh before others we're
just biologically morally
driven that way and and those two things
are always intention they always have
been and always will be so there's
there's never going to be a permanent
solution um to the civility challenge uh
in our world today and there never has
been but but what we can do is look to
the wisdom of the past look to how
thoughtful people have have um have have
advised that we overcome this tension
before and help us live live well
together
the forthcoming book is against
politeness why politeness failed america
and how civility can save it we've been
speaking with the author alexandra
hudson an award-winning award-winning
journalist author and speaker really
appreciate your time and your insights
today thanks so much for having me david